there is a recent paper that i am going
to link in the show notes they were
looking at beta alanine supplementation
uh 6.4 grams per day the cumulative dose
should have been adequate to achieve an
ergogenic effect um you know in theory
um
but unfortunately you know within this
program that the participants were doing
about 12 reps per set
three sets per exercise going to you
know concentric failure
and resting a minute between sets
resting two minutes between exercises
beta alanine in this particular study
really just didn't do much at all in
terms of facilitating hypertrophy or
facilitating strength gains i think it
was eight maybe ten weeks or so in
duration uh so the dose per day was high
enough the duration was long enough the
cumulative dose should have been
sufficient for beta alanine to do what
it's supposed to do and in this case uh
you know beta alanine just really didn't
do much for this program now it was an
eight-week study eight-week study yeah
that's what i thought
um so
the uh
the uh takeaway here is based on this
research based on this particular study
not very promising for the people who
like to use beta alanine within the
context of a pretty standard pretty
typical hypertrophy program
now
nine or ten people per group one study
of course we don't want to get too
carried away and kind of put the nail in
the coffin of beta-alanine
but there's not really a ton of research
suggesting that beta-alanine directly is
efficacious within this type of training
program and here is one piece of
evidence that chips away at some of our
confidence in that conclusion and so for
me going into this study um my suspicion
was that if you were doing sets of 12 go
into failure only one minute of rest
between sets i would have anticipated a
small benefit from beta alanine and when
i say small
when you're talking about standardized
effect size categories what i really
mean is trivial but for a lot of people
trivial matters uh in terms of you know
if it's non-zero reliably we'll take it
in a lot of cases so i was expecting
probably a
trivial effect of beta alanine in this
context uh that's not what was observed
and we're gonna need some more research
to really dig into this to figure out
exactly how specialized beta alanine is
for lifters uh you know we know for
certain um well
that's about as as bold as statements
i'd ever make so there is a very large
body of evidence suggesting that beta
alanine is effective when you are doing
you know truly purely anaerobic
glycolytic sprint type exercise when
you're if you're doing exhaustive bouts
of exercise that are two minutes in
duration and you're doing several of
them like beta alanine
ought to help in that scenario there's
plenty of evidence to suggest that but
when it comes to lifting applications
this study
uh like i said chips away at our
confidence that it has a lot of utility
in a typical hypertrophy program with
that kind of standard hypertrophy rep
range and the standard one or two
minutes of rest between sets uh i still
believe uh based on
mostly mechanistic uh theory
that beta alanine probably has
applications when it comes to things
like crossfit uh other forms of circuit
type training strongman medleys possibly
uh depending on exactly how the medley's
put together uh so i i'm not ready to
say
that beta alanine is useless for
hypertrophy or for the typical
hypertrophy program but um we
we don't yet have a definitive line
where we say
these are the programming uh
characteristics that make use of beta
alanine and these are the programming
characteristics at which it becomes
useless we don't really know where that
line is and we don't know which side of
the line
uh typical hypertrophy programming falls
on so it's an area where we're going to
need some more research and like i said
if you're
into hypertrophy focused training
and uh you've been using beta alanine
because uh you know you
like me anticipated that it would be at
least somewhat helpful in these
applications uh like i said this could
be good news or bad news uh it could be
good news because you say oh great i
don't have to spend money on it anymore
and i don't have to you know take the
two grams like you know three or four
times throughout the day depending on
how you split it up so you know beta
alanine is kind of a pain to dose
several times throughout the day to
avoid all the tingling um so you might
look at this as a good thing or you
might look at it as a bad thing because
you say hey i
i kind of have that sunk cost where i've
been using beta alanine for so long and
paying for it i was hoping it was doing
something for me maybe it's not
again i want to reiterate we're talking
about small sample research we're
talking about one finding we shouldn't
get too carried away um but i do think
there's a a perspective
that's very common which is that beta
alanine is a slam dunk for hypertrophy
type training and i don't think we're
quite ready to make that type of
conclusion yet